[Music]
russia's massive division of his
democratic neighbor ukraine has drawn
sharp condemnation from all over the
world here in new york ukraine's u.n
ambassador turned directly to russia's
ambassador last night and said this
quote there is no purgatory for war
criminals they go straight to hell join
us now with some perspective is ian
bremmer the president and founder of
your razor group and g zero media good
morning and how you doing to you good to
see you guys so you called this a moment
um a turning point and global order you
said there will be thousands of innocent
civilian lives that will be at cost um
where do you see this going um this is
uh now a cold war
between the united states and all of its
allies very unified on this issue uh and
russia and that means uh we've we're
cutting off diplomatic engagement uh
we're cutting off economic engagement uh
you know for the last 30 years no one
was living through a cuban missile
crisis moment no one thought that you
had the potential for military
confrontation in europe anymore that is
gone today you have 200 000 russian
troops that have been built up and
arrayed all along ukrainian support
ukraine's borders and they are now
invading and they are
going to be massive does this have to be
another cold war it's an elementary
question but i think it's probably in
the minds of many americans as they wake
up this morning do we have to contest
this taking of ukraine or potential
taking of ukraine i think we do
because i think that we worked uh over
the course of the last several months to
tell the russians very clearly and in a
united fashion
that an invasion of ukraine while we
would not defend them directly
we consider them a legitimate democracy
we believe in their self-determination
that means that we have already sent
them uh a significant amount of war
materiel that they are using to defend
themselves we have sent troops to the
front lines in the baltic states uh in
poland in romania in bulgaria
nato is now going to have functionally
a border
right up against a hostile
russia-controlled ukraine and there'll
be partisan fighting on the ground in
ukraine i think it's incredibly hard
given putin's decision to put this genie
back in the bottle
putin says that he's not intending to
occupy ukraine he just wants to
demilitarize the country what does that
even mean it means he's lying um putin
has told us for the last two months he's
told biden he's told macron he's told
schultz he's told johnson that he has no
intention of invading ukraine he's lied
in consistent and staggering fashion and
so tragically for the ukrainian people
they're now saying they have no
intention to occupy ukraine but russia
has already said that they consider that
the ukrainian nation is a part of russia
it is very clear that they intend to
overthrow this ukrainian government and
they intend to integrate it in some way
within a broader russian structure if if
another country interferes putin warned
consequences greater than any have seen
in history any of you have seen in
history is that an overt nuclear threat
i guess it is but it's cheap because the
united states and all the nato allies
have already made very clear to
president putin that they will not put
troops on the ground to defend ukraine
itself it's not a member of nato it has
no membership action plan what putin is
saying is that this country is mine i am
taking it i am working to reintegrate
russian empire keep in mind that putin
has said on the record many times that
he considers the dissolution of the
soviet union to be the greatest
geopolitical tragedy of the 20th century
and he believes that it is his legacy to
reverse that that is the message that he
is presently sending and he's willing to
spill russian blood never mind ukrainian
blood
we've already seen planes get shot down
over the last 24 hours i mean there's
shut down right absolutely i mean this
is putin saying i am going to make it my
legacy by enemies necessary by all means
that's right now you've also said that
they have turned into an international
pariah a parade that occupies a lot of
the economic space globally and now how
do you go about crippling russia's
economical infrastructure without taking
down the international
economic balance well two points first
it's going to be very costly
particularly for the europeans the
united states have very little
dependence economically on russia but
the europeans in terms of gas in terms
of trade and agriculture in terms of you
know investment from oligarchs that's
going away so you're going to have
significant spike in gas costs for the
europeans you'll have shortages this
will probably have an impact of i'd say
you know one point of gdp on much of
europe minimum over the course of the
year but beyond what you do to russia
there's also the question of how does
this affect china right because the
americans are putting sanctions on
russia and the chinese aren't going to
want to break those sanctions which why
the chinese have been critical of
increasing sanctions final point is
sanctions can only do so much putin
knows what's coming he knew it was
coming yesterday he knows what's coming
today the maximum level of u.s and
european sanctions that will go on
russia and that the biggest sanctions
that will ever have been imposed on a
major power post-soviet collapse will be
less than what we've seen or roughly
about what we've seen on iran so if
sanctions can only do so much how far
should the u.s go i i think you still
have to go there
you still go there but is that what does
go there mean though well go there means
that nordstrom 2 the pipeline with
germany's cost 11 billion dollars to
build is dead it will not be used by the
russians
let's cut to the chase here i mean
legally we have no obligation right now
to protect ukraine we don't have to be
involved at all that's right but we have
nato partners that are on the border of
uh poland poland borders ukraine uh and
then they're the baltic states former
soviet states that's right in your view
putin wants those back so do you think
this war is coming to nato um that's a
hot war i i don't believe that but i
believe that putin will sense weakness
and division and he'll play on it and
one of the reasons why you have to go
there in maximal fashion with the
sanctions is because you're protecting
the baltic states you're protecting
poland if the americans were now to say
ah we need to be able to do business
with the russians the europeans say the
same thing you could break nato i mean
i've had those conversations directly
with the leadership of nato in the last
several days i was just the munich
security conference like there's the
nato is incredibly unified right now
that is the one silver lining that you
can take away from all this there are
very few okay ann bremmer thank you so
much for joining us